Let's start with a quick exercise.
I'd like you to force your face into a smile.
Don't just sit there, actually give it a go.
Force your face into a smile.
Now hold that expression.
Everyone knows that when they feel happy they smile,...
...but research shows the opposite is also true.
When you force your face into a smile you start to feel happier.
Keep smiling.
The same is true of how you talk and even walk.
If you put energy into your voice and a spring in your step...
...you'll suddenly feel much better.
Okay, you can stop smiling now.
How do you feel?
Did it work for you?
I hope so.
And next time you want a quick dose of delight,...
...just spend thirty seconds or so behaving like a happy person.